salut les épicurieuses et les epicurieux
vous entendez
il y a de l'orage dans l'air j'aime pas
trop ça et vous on dit que dans une
telle situation il ne faut pas rester
sous un arbre ni ouvrir un parapluie
alors est-ce vraiment dangereux quel
comportement faut-il adopter pour se
protéger aujourd'hui je réponds à toutes
les questions que vous vous posez sur
les orages dans l'atelier
j'ai senti une goutte ne restons pas là
ça va nous tomber sur la tête
savez-vous en quelle saison il y a le
plus d'orages en France compte en
moyenne
453.000 impacts de foudre par an dans
notre pays mais c'est au mois de juillet
et d'août quand il fait le plus chaud
qu'ils sont le plus nombreux le record
en une journée le 6 août 1999
600335 éclairs entre les nuages et le
sol toute la France ce qui impressionne
le plus quand il y a de l'orage ce sont
des éclairs comment se forme-t-il un
orage éclate lorsque l'air est chaud et
humide et que le ciel se charge
d'énormes nuages sombres qu'on appelle
les kumulonimbus ce sont de véritables
monstres ils peuvent s'élever jusqu'à
15000 mètres d'altitude et sont capables
d'aspirer
9000 tonnes d'eau par seconde c'est à
l'intérieur ou à partir de ces nuages
que les éclairs vont se former tout
s'est terminé qui a pris de l'altitude
laisse forcément un vide que d'autres
masse d'air souvent humides elles aussi
sont presque de remplacer à l'intérieur
du culot Namus l'air monte très vite en
prenant de l'altitude l'eau avec le
froid se transforme en cristaux c'est
cristaux s'agglomère et forment des
grains de Grésilles de plus en plus gros
qui une fois trop lourd donc dans leur
descente il croise et heurte d'autres
grains de grésiles tout juste formé qui
eux sont en pleine ascension les
collisions provoquent un transfert de
charges électriques durant leur chute
les grains de grésil arrachent des
électrons des charges négatives au grain
qui monte qui du coup deviennent
positifs ainsi la base du cumulonimbus
se charge négativement tandis que le
sommet accumule des charges positives le
vous le voyez devient alors une sorte
d'énormes pile électrique avec un pôle
positif là-haut et un pôle négatif à la
base quand la différence de potentiel
est trop importante entre la base et le
sommet le courant passe en générant un
éclair à l'intérieur du nuage on appelle
ça des éclairs intra nuageux quand deux
cumulonimbus sont relativement proches
ça peut aller jusqu'à une centaine de
kilomètres il peut y avoir des éclairs
entre les deux on les appelle des
éclairs inter nuageux la tension d'un
éclair peut atteindre 100 millions de
volts et une température de 30 000
degrés oui mais moi ce qui me fait peur
c'est la foudre qui s'abat sur le
plancher des vaches j'y viens
en temps normal d'un point de vue
électrique le sol est neutre
c'est-à-dire qu'il y a autant de charges
négatives que de charges positives
maintenant il faut savoir que dans la
nature les charges électriques de même
signe se repoussent comme lorsque l'on
approche les deux pauses identiques d'un
aimant la base du nuage est à moins de
2000 mètres du sol c'est suffisant pour
que les charges négatives présentent
dans le sol soit repoussé par les
charges négatives présentes à la base du
nuage une zone chargée positivement ce
format alors sous le nuage là encore une
différence de potentiel s'installe entre
la base du nuage et le sol et quand elle
devient trop importante un courant
électrique se ferait un passage entre
les deux bornes c'est la foudre
alors souvent on entend dire que la
foudre peut s'abattre n'importe où c'est
vrai mais le relief il est quand même
pour quelque chose les charges
électriques ont tendance à s'accumuler
au niveau des points saillants
à signe des arbres la foudre va donc
s'abattre sur ses pointes parce que le
chemin est plus court et parce qu'elles
sont plus chargées
c'est ce qu'on appelle l'effet de pointe
alors quand l'orage se déclenche il vaut
mieux s'éloigner de ses points hauts et
saillants pas tenir un parapluie ouvert
ou un autre objet métallique alors si
j'étais toi je ne resterai pas sous cet
arbre avec ton parapluie
c'est un orage éclate n'attendez pas au
premier signe visuel ou sonore
mettez-vous à l'abri et si vous êtes
coincé à l'extérieur
n'allez surtout pas vous réfugier sous
un arbre et faites pointe mais ne restez
pas non plus planté comme une tige
et faites pointe également non
accroupissez-vous et serrez les pieds
comme ceci
voilà c'est sûr je serre les fesses
quand la foudre s'abat sur le sol un
courant électrique très puissant circule
dans celui-ci si quelqu'un se trouve sur
le passage du courant il y a de fortes
chances qu'il fasse un détour par son
organisme les tissus humains sont bien
meilleurs conducteurs que le sol d'une
prairie le courant rentre par un pied
circule dans l'organisme
et ressort par l'autre c'est ce qu'on
appelle l'effet de pas ce phénomène est
très dangereux il provoque parfois la
mort d'animaux dans les champs des
vaches ou des moutons en se tenant
accroupis et les pieds serrés
les mains posées sur les genoux la
différence de potentiel entre les pieds
s'allume complètement et le courant
électrique ne passe plus dans
l'organisme il reste dans le sol autre
solution pour se protéger la voiture
elle constitue une excellente protection
contre la foudre la carrosserie
métallique forme une cage dite de
Faraday l'électricité reste à la surface
de la cage et ne pénètre pas à
l'intérieur c'est le même phénomène qui
protège les passagers des avions quand
ils traversent une zone orageuse il y
aura-je dit éclair mais aussi coup de
tonnerre les seconds font d'ailleurs
souvent plus peur que les premiers alors
qu'est-ce qui provoque ce bruit quand le
courant passe il provoque un
échauffement l'air à cet endroit se
dilate violemment ce phénomène génère
une onde sonore qui va se déplacer
jusqu'à nos oreilles en faisant vibrer
les molécules d'air c'est ce qui est à
l'origine du coup de tonnerre au passage
vous avez bien sûr remarqué que le son
et l'image je n'arrive jamais à vos yeux
et à vos oreilles au même moment on voit
d'abord l'éclair puis on entend le
tonnerre
si l'image est le son sont décalés c'est
parce qu'ils ne se déplace pas à la même
manière dans un air à 15 degrés et au
niveau de la mer le son voyage à environ
340 mètres par seconde il va beaucoup
moins vite que la lumière qui elle se
déplace à 300 mille kilomètres par
seconde l'éclair et la détonation se
produisent donc au même moment mais
l'image se forme presque instantanément
sur la rétine de l'observateur tandis
que le son mais parfois plusieurs
secondes pour atteindre ses oreilles le
temps que la vibration des molécules
d'air se propage de proche en proche
jusqu'à cet un temps pour estimer la
distance qui nous sépare du lieu
d'impact de la foudre il suffit donc de
compter les secondes à partir du moment
où l'on voit l'éclair puis de multiplier
par 340 si la détonation parvient au
bout de 5 secondes cela signifie que la
foudre est tombée
5 fois 340 1700 mètres plus loin si
c'est cool 10 secondes la foudre est
tombée à environ 3400 mètres et pour
savoir s'il faut se mettre à l'abri et
bien il suffit de compter aucun ou de
violents orages s'annonce dans votre
région n'hésitez pas à vous rendre sur
le site vigilance Météo France il vous
indiquera tous les comportements à
suivre vous éloignez des arbres et des
cours d'eau par exemple vous abritez
dans un bâtiment en dur ne pas utiliser
votre téléphone ou d'autres appareils
électriques si ces orages s'accompagnent
de très fortes précipitations rejoignez
au plus vite un point haut ou
abritez-vous à l'étage enfin si vous
circulez en voiture ne vous engagez pas
sur une routine immergée même
partiellement le courant pourrait vous
emporter merci d'avoir regardé cette
vidéo j'espère que vous avez compris
qu'en cas d'orage le ciel ne risque pas
de nous tomber sur la tête et que vous
avez bien mesuré les dangers
[Musique]